(birds tweeting)
- [Announcer] Rapidly growing,
consuming,
adapting,
they conquer.
Jeopardizing local economies,
threatening human health, and
devastating entire ecosystems.
- [Man] As whole rows of
cherished landmarks are condemned
brought home to town-dwelling citizens
are the rigid precautions being taken
by the Department of Agriculture
to save this tree from extinction.
- [Announcer] Invasive species
are non-native organisms
that cause considerable damage
when introduced to a new area.
These species compete with
native wildlife for resources,
and thrive at the expense
of the local ecosystem.
(tree crashing)
The introduction of invasive species
is often associated with human activity.
Boats that travel between
different bodies of water
can carry hitchhikers,
such as the zebra mussel.
One of the most notorious invasive species
in the United States, these
rapidly reproducing mussels
clog pipes and over take
beaches in the Great Lakes.
Some invasive species, however,
are introduced intentionally.
(frog croaking)
In the early 20th century,
cane toads were brought to Australia
as a form of pest control.
Today, these poisonous
amphibians number in the millions
and have cause a decline in
native predators on the island.
It's not just animals.
Bacteria, fungi, and plants
can also become invasive.
Brought to South Africa
in the 19th century,
the black wattle is an invasive tree
often used for timber and firewood.
This beautiful tree, and
other thirsty invasives,
are depleting the country's
already record-low water supply.
Because of their impact on human health,
ecosystems, and infrastructure,
invasive species cost the global economy
over a trillion dollars each year.
Many measures can be taken
to help limit the spread
of invasive species,
but the most effective
method is prevention.
By carefully cleaning boats
before transferring between
different bodies of water,
not releasing exotic pets into the wild,
and planting gardens with native species,
we can help prevent the
spread of invasive organisms.
Every living thing has evolved
to play a specialized role
within their ecosystem.
In the ultimate balancing
act, even one invasive species
can drastically tilt the scales.
If we stay mindful of our role
in the spread of these organisms,
we can prevent invasions
before it is too late.
(gentle cinematic music)